because of what we did because of what
the federal government did
luckily the disease did not go as high
as they thought in the projections you
now have the corresponding question how
fast is the decline how low is the
decline and again the variable is going
to be what we do we change the
projection on the way up we can change
the projection on the way down but it's
purely dependent on what we do
are we socially distancing are we
testing how fast do we reopen how do we
reopen you answer those questions and
you will determine what the rate of
decline is if you say well we're done
can't stay in the house anymore let's
just reopen just start business tomorrow
let's go what happens that's what
happens all the progress we made is gone
and all experts or virtually all experts
will say not only does the virus spread
increase but it increases to a higher
point than we had increased the first
time again this is a remarkably
effective virus at spreading and growing
so I know everyone's impatient let's
just reopen that's what happens if we
just reopen so we have to be smart
people are also talking about a second
wave potential of the second wave people
are talking about potential for the
virus to come back in the fall which
means the game isn't over which means
the game could be just at halftime so
let's make sure we're learning the
lessons of what has happened thus far
and let's make sure we're being truthful
with ourselves that we're deceiving
anyone else but let's make sure we're
not deceiving ourselves
what has happened what should we learn
from as far as what has happened thus
far so we make sure we don't make the
same mistakes again and let's do that
now this was our first global pandemic
welcome there had been people who talked
about global pandemics before Bill Gates
had talked about the potential of a
global pandemic during the Obama
administration they thought about being
prepared for a global pandemic but it
was almost always an academic exercise
what if what if would have once it
happens once it actualizes for people
then it's different then people get it
we now know that a global pandemic is
not just the textbook exercise it's not
just the tabletop exercise it can happen
and when it happens it's devastating and
let's just learn from what happened on
the first one let's just get the basic
lesson of what happened on the first one
last November December we knew that
China had a virus outbreak you could
read about it in the newspapers right
everybody knew January 26 we know we had
the first confirmed case in Seattle
Washington in California February 2nd
the President ordered a travel ban from
China
March 1st we have the first confirmed
case in the state of New York by March
19th New York State is totally closed
down
no no State moved faster from first case
to closed down than the state of New
York
March 16th we have a full travel ban
from Europe researchers now find and
they report in some newspapers the virus
was spreading wildly in Italy in
February and there was an outbreak
massive outbreak in Italy in February
researchers now say there were likely
28,000 cases in the United States in
February including 10,000 cases in the
state of New York
and the coronavirus flu that virus that
came to New York did not come from China
it came from Europe okay when you look
at the number of flights that came from
Europe to New York the New York
metropolitan area New York and New
Jersey during January February up to the
closed-down thirteen thousand flights
bringing 2.2 million people all right so
November December you have the outbreak
in China everybody knows January
February flights are coming from Europe
people are also coming from China in
January until the China closed down and
the flights continued to come from
Europe until the Europe shut down 2.2
million people come to New York and come
to New Jersey we acted two months after
the China outbreak when you look back
does anyone think the virus was still in
China waiting for us to act two months
later we all talk about the global
economy and how fast people move and how
mobile we are how can you expect that
when you act two months after the
outbreak in China the virus was only in
China waiting for us to act the horse
had already left the barn by the time we
moved a researcher now says knowing the
number of flights coming into New York
from Italy it was like watching a
horrible train wreck in slow motion
those are the flights that were coming
from Italy and from Europe January in
February we closed the front door with
the China travel ban which was right
even in retrospect it was right but we
left the back door open because the
virus had
China by the time we did the China
travel thing that's what the researchers
are now saying with 28,000 cases in the
United States 10,000 in New York so what
is the lesson an outbreak anywhere is an
outbreak everywhere when you see in
November and December and outbreak in
China just assume the next day it's in
the United States when they say it's in
China just assume that virus got on a
plane that night and flew to New York or
flew to Newark Airport and it's now in
New York that has to be the operating
mentality because you don't know that
the virus didn't get on a plane all you
need is one person to get on that plane
in China and come to New York the way
this virus transfers that's all you need
and you can assume two months later the
virus is still going to be sitting on a
park bench in China waiting for you to
get there that is the lesson and again
why do we need to learn the lesson
because they're talking about this
happening again with this virus where it
could mutate in China and get on a plane
and come right back
or the next virus or the next pandemic
whose job is it to warn us of these
global pandemics the president says it's
the World Health Organization and that's
why he's taken action against them not
my field but he's right to ask the
question because this was too little too
late and let's find out what happened so
it doesn't happen again and it will
happen again Bank on it let's not put
our head in the sand and say this is the
only global pandemic that will
to deal with in the meantime let's keep
moving forward one of the things we're
working on is how do we clean how do we
disinfect we're talking about reopening
we still have public transit systems
running we still have buses running so
we've been working on how do you come up
with new cleaning new disinfecting
protocols and I ask the simple question
to our team a few days ago how long does
the virus live and it's something we
need to know but frankly I think it's
something everybody needs to know the
virus can live up to 72 hours on plastic
surfaces and stainless steel surfaces
okay so just think about this from a
transit point of view or from your car
point of view it can live on a vinyl car
seat up to 72 hours it can live on a
pole in a bus or on a seat in a bus for
up to 72 hours up to 24 hours on
cardboard up to 4 hours on materials
like copper and the droplets can hang in
the air for 3 hours this was a shocker
to me when they were talking about
droplets I thought it was a droplet and
then it falls right it's a droplet that
can hang in the air for three hours I
don't even know how that works and many
of the people who spread it are showing
no symptoms at all
so just factor that in in your daily
life when you're going through your own
precautions we're also going to do the
state finance report this week and what
you're going to see is what we expected
roughly a thirteen point three billion
dollar shortfall from our forecast total
effect all over the period of the
financial plan is 61 billion dollars now
what happened new york state was not
quote-unquote in trouble before this
happened
New York State was very very strong
before this happened our economy was
growing it was growing very at a very
high rate our government spending has
been at record lows the spending
increases our taxes today are lower than
the day I took office oh you're a
Democrat how can that be that's in
numbers tax rates on individuals
businesses are lower today than the day
I took office every tax rate as
incredible as that sounds is lower today
than the day I took office so the state
finances were very very strong and then
this economic tsunami hits and you shut
down all the businesses everybody stays
home they're not getting a paycheck they
feel like economic anxiety the
consequence of the state is the revenue
projections are way down what do we do
about it some people have suggested well
states should declare bankruptcy
I think as I said yesterday it's a
really dumb idea people are trying to
talk about bringing the economy back
reopen we have to get the economy moving
again and then rather than provide
financial aid to the states that got hit
by this economic tsunami so through no
fault of their own suggestion was made
state should declare bankruptcy little
few problems with that premise
forget the morality of it and the ethics
of it and the the absurdity of it and
the meanness of it legally a state can't
declare bankruptcy you would need a
federal law allowing States to declare
bankruptcy so to the Senate that
proposed it I say pass a law allowing
States to declare bankruptcy I dare you
and let the president sign that bill
that says I give the states the legal
ability to declare bankruptcy
it's your suggestion
Senator McConnell pass the law I dare
you
and then go to the President and say
sign this bill allowing States to
declare bankruptcy you want to send the
signal to the markets that this nation
is in real trouble you want to send a
international message that the economy
is in turmoil do that allow states to
declare bankruptcy legally because you
passed the bill it'll be the first time
in our nation's history that that
happened I dare you to do that and then
we'll see how many states actually take
you up on it I know I wouldn't but if
you believe what you said and you have
the courage of conviction because you're
a man of your word pass that bill if you
weren't just playing politics we'll see
how long it takes them to do it
also moving on voting we still have
elections in the midst of all this chaos
we've seen elections held where we have
people on lines for a long period of
time it makes no sense to me to tell
people you have to put your life at risk
violate social distancing to come out to
vote so we passed an executive order
that said you can vote by absentee today
I'm asking the Board of Elections to
send every New York voter a a what's
called a automatically receives a
postage-paid application for a ballot if
you want to vote we should send you a
ballot so you can vote so you don't have
to come out and get online and then
looking ahead more testing and we are
making great progress on that in New
York State is doing more tests than any
state in the country right now New York
State is doing more tests than any
country per capita on the globe right
now
that is what will educate I'm moving
forward watch the spread of the virus
it's getting warmer more people are
going to be coming out of their homes
that's going to happen naturally watch
that spread testing gives you those
numbers on an ongoing basis maintain
social distancing also plan on a
reopening and not just reopening what
was we went through this horrific
experience it should be a period of
growth it should be a period of
reflection if we're smart and we use it
that way there are lessons to learn here
if we're smart and we have the courage
to look in the mirror we went through
9/11 we were the smarter for it we went
through World War two we were the better
for it we went through superstorm sandy
we learned we grew we were the better
for it we should do the same thing here
people have totally changed their
lifestyle what did we learn how do we
have a better healthcare system that can
actually handle public health
emergencies how do we have a better
transportation system how do we have a
smarter telemedicine system how do we
use technology and education better why
do some children have to go to a parking
lot to get Wi-Fi to do their homework
how do we how do we learn from this and
how do we grow and let New York lead the
way because we are New York tough but
New York tough when they say we're tough
yeah we're tough but we think tough
incorporates being smart and being
disciplined and being unified and being
loving last point I want to make is and
this is just personal it's not factual
my grandmother on my father's side Mary
was a beautiful woman but tough she was
a tough lady
she was New York tough gone through the
depression early immigrant worked hard
or low life and she was a little rough
young she was rough you and I would say
to her you know grandma
met this girl met this guy they're
really nice and she would say nice how
do you know they're nice it's easy to be
nice when everything is nice what does
that mean she said now you know and then
you know if they're nice when things get
hard that's when you know if they're
nice and I never really got it but her
point was it's easy to be nice and kind
and affable when everything is easy you
really get to see people and get to see
character when things get hard and when
the pressure is on is when you really
get to see true colors of a person and
see what they're made of it's almost as
if the pressure just forces their
character and the weaknesses explode or
the strengths explode and that's what
we've gone through this has been hard
it's put everyone under pressure and
you've really seen what people are made
of and you've really had a snapshot of
what individuals are made of and what we
are made of as a collective and
personally I'll tell you the truth some
people break your heart they just break
your heart people who I thought would
rise to the occasion people who I
thought was strong under pressure they
just crumbled they just crumbled on the
other hand you see people who you didn't
expect anything from who just rise to
the occasion and you see the best and
you see the worst you just see the best
and the worst of humanity just comes up
to the surface on both ends
it just everything gets elevated the
strength in people and the weakness in
people the beauty in people and the
ugliness in people you see both for me
the beauty you see and the strength
that you see compensates and balances
for the weakness and I get inspired by
the strength so I can tolerate the
heartbreak of the weakness here's a
letter that I received that just sums it
up dear mr. Cuomo I seriously doubt that
you will ever read this letter as I know
you are busy beyond belief with a
disaster that has befallen our country
we are a nation in crisis of that there
is no doubt I am a retired farmer
hunkered down in northeast Kansas with
my wife who has but one long and
occasional problems with her remaining
lung she also has diabetes we are in our
70s now and frankly I am afraid for her
enclosed find a solitary n95 mask left
over from my farming days it has never
been used if you could would you please
give this mask to a nurse or doctor in
your state I have kept for masks for my
immediate family please keep on doing
what you do so well with just elite
sincerely Dennis and Sharon a farmer in
northeast Kansas his wife has one lung
and diabetes he is five masks he sends
one mask to New York for a doctor or
nurse keeps four masks you want to talk
about a snapshot of humanity you have
five masks what do you do do you keep
all five do you hide the five masks do
you keep them for yourselves or
there's no you send one mask one mask to
New York to help a nurse or a doctor how
beautiful is that
I mean how selfless is that how giving
is that you know that's the nursing home
in Niskayuna that sent 100 ventilators
down to New York City when they needed
them it's that love that courage that
generosity of spirit that makes this
country so beautiful and makes American
so beautiful
and it's that generosity of spirit for
me makes up for all the ugliness that
you see take one mask
I'll keep for god bless america
questions i don't know much about UV
rays not my job not my business not my
education at my background dr. Zucker
what do you know about UV right think
that anything when it comes to bleach
this is these are chemicals you wouldn't
you would not ingest and as we know we
make sure our kids do not go into
cabinets that have any of these
chemicals in them so need to stay away
from those products that's what we've
been talking about for the past two days
that I had a meeting in the White House
and the president and his team are going
to work on the supply chain issue for
the national manufacturers to get the
reagents test kits so they can provide
our commercial labs here in New York and
we want to go from a goal of we're not
doing about 20,000 a day we want to go
to 40,000 a day Karen
let's keep of the mail-in voting for the
June 23rd primary people on both the
left and the right are saying can be not
be a good idea because the Board of
Elections is not up to carrying out this
task so with pulse still be open for
people to go to yes rolls would be open
and you think the Board of Elections can
carry this out are there problems with
Karen life is options you have an
election there is only two options
either people go to the polls or people
vote by absentee there's no other way to
do it right we're saying you have both
options you can go to the poll or you
can vote absentee I don't know what else
anyone could expect anyone could do what
is the other option people on the left
and the right are unhappy what do they
recommend right there are only two
things you have an election you can go
to the poll that day or if you don't
want to go to the poll you vote option T
we're doing both then if you're against
absentee then everybody goes to the
polls is that what they want no they
don't want that either because they
don't want people going to the polls
because then you wait online and you
come in contact with other people right
so life is actually spring of it yeah
just wondering so are you sending an
absentee application or an actual ballot
Melissa we're sending an absentee
application so article 2 section 2 of
the Constitution allows for an absentee
voting process and there are two
provisions one if you're out of County
the other is a list of specific things
that were in numenera numerated in law
by the legislature one of those is
temporary illness the executive order
the governor did a couple of weeks ago
amended the temporary illness provision
to include risk of contracting koban so
we looked at this very closely I know
some people thought that this should be
you send everybody an actual ballot to
vote and we don't think that that's
within our constitutional right for the
governor's directive powers
to override the Constitution create of
Mahlon voting system one otherwise
doesn't exist so what we're saying is
everyone's gonna get an application with
postage so this is easy every registered
voter gets one they can fill it out they
send it back in and to the question of
whether or not the Board of Elections
can handle this the provision the
governor did a couple of weeks ago
allowed for anyone to already be able to
do this it's just that then you would
have had to download the ballot call to
get a ballot go to the BOE to get the
ballot so all we're doing is making this
more convenient so that people who don't
have access to Internet don't want to
leave their homes because of their fear
of kovat are able to get an application
directly sent to them with the return
postage to be able to get the absentee
ballot that our early executive order
allowed for how smart is that away from
May first millions of New Yorkers have
rent - they have mortgages - have you
given any thought to a rent freeze for
renters or to extend mortgages by that
three months so that those loans would
be extended so that people aren't going
to be facing a kind of a large payment
when your moratorium is complete yeah
we're looking at that right now
what do we do at the end of this
moratorium we have a number of options
we're looking at we're looking at all
options question we're now three weeks
away from when the on pause order is
supposed to be done May 15th parents are
trying to figure out whether or not
their kids are going back to school can
we get a timetable and when you might
make that decision about one week about
one so we give people some notice rent
freeze in New York City that's
controlled by the rent board in New York
City and that's entirely controlled by
New York City I know mayor de Blasio has
been calling for them to do the rent
freeze but that's outside of our actual
jurisdiction that's controlled by the
city that's something that we're looking
at but the pressure has obviously been
in the city and that's what the
conversation has been and that's
something that I know the mayor's
focused on it's really an issue in New
York City was well the New York City
decision New York City has to make what
we do on our our executive orders that
are going to expire we have a couple of
we have a couple of weeks still so we'll
give people timely notice but we're
looking at a lot
melissa - spearheading it but has there
been any update there on the safety of
pregnant women giving birth during the
pandemic and just how is that work we're
gonna be giving the governor a list of
recommendations this weekend for
executive action so you'll be seeing
something in the next couple of days but
we've been meeting every day this week
[Music]
we're looking at that now and we don't
have a decision now but I'll tell you
the truth the I said to the federal
government I've been talking about this
for how long two months two months I
said how can you have a federal
government in a position where they're
not going to provide funding to state
governments and local governments small
business airlines business program now
some of these large corporations now
apparently you've been taking money from
the government programs and they're not
funding state and local when you don't
fund state local you know who you don't
fund police fire school teachers school
officials what was the possible theory
of funding large corporations but not
firefighters and that police and not
healthcare workers I mean it boggles the
mind and all they said was don't worry
right don't worry we're gonna do it in
the next bill we're gonna do it in the
next bill we're gonna do it in the next
bill I said to the our congressional
delegation I said to our senators
Schumer and Gillibrand don't pass this
passed bill that they just did unless
you have state and local funding because
they're not gonna do it don't worry
don't worry they're not going to do it
as soon as the Senate acts McConnell
turns around and says I'm not going to
do it the state should declare
bankruptcy bailout to the blue states
bailout to the blue states again the
most unamerican uncharitable
ugly statement of all times yes New York
had more current virus cases than cannot
Kentucky you know why the flights from
Europe land in New York the flights were
not landing in Kentucky that's why we
have the coronavirus cases that's what
the researchers now found two months
later
that's a virus one from China to Europe
got on the plane and came here and by
the way the virus probably got on a
plane in China and came here
but China maybe landed in California the
European flights landed here that's why
New York has a corona virus cases bail
out New York you're not bailing out in
New York New York has bailed you out
every year it's bailed you out Mitch
McConnell is a taker not a giver New
York is the state of givers we put more
money into the federal pot every year
with a number one state in donating to
the federal pot number one Kentucky is
the number three state in taking from
the federal power they take out more
from the federal pot than they put in
every year every year but this is
America state's one federal pot you put
in what you can and the states that need
it take it okay so for every year New
York was the number one donor state
putting in more money than it took out
putting in more money than anyone else
and taking out less number one donor
state Kentucky every year was the number
three state that took out more than they
put in
so they will litter we were putting
money into the pot they were taking our
dollars out of the pot and now he wants
to look at New York and say we're
bailing you out you're bailing us out
just give me my money back senator just
give me my money back I mean it's just
ridiculous they should declare
bankruptcy okay senator pass the bill
that authorizes states to declare
bankruptcy sign the bill mr. president
economy's coming back we're doing great
pent up the man
stock market wants to take off good pass
a bill allowing States to be bankrupt
and then let's watch how the stock
market takes off at that great news
about our economic resilience they all
have been sent the portal has been made
100% available to all nursing homes no
if you get a list nursing home goes
online here's the whole list go to the
list there are 60,000 people hire
whoever you want they all said that they
were available and they want to help
thank you first of all I actually wanted
to tell you something I've been speaking
with reporters from other states and one
from Arizona it told me last night that
the state officials they are not giving
any information on kovat 19 so I wanted
to say thank you for taking our
questions oh thank you very much thank
you former reporter says surprises never
cease there is the positive of this
coronavirus the reporter says thank you
States have submitted their reopening
plans we haven't heard the entire list
of states I wanted to know are we on the
list and in terms of reopening is the
plan anywhere near being done for New
York we're not on the list if you look
at the 16 states those tend to be the
states that had a lower infection rate
lower hospitalization rate lower death
rate we're not in the first 16 in terms
of just on the numbers on the data also
our plan will have a statewide plan
would you basically be focused on
lessons learned but then we're also
doing a regional analysis because in
this state some of the states are are
basically homogeneous New York is
anything but homogeneous we have the
most dense urban area in New York City
and then we have rural areas that could
be in Ohio or could be in Montana I mean
you know we have areas where you have
very few people basically agricultural
so we have both and that's why we're
saying we'll do a regional analysis
depending on the numbers some regions
could open up before others as long as
the way we open up those regions don't
cause unintended consequences where they
wind up with different problems because
everybody now comes to drive-in to go to
their beaches or their parks or their
businesses etc you know you open up Main
Street now anywhere in the state of New
York you'll see people in their cars
driving up from New York City to go to
that Main Street I have no doubt you see
these pictures of beaches opening up
your people will drive hours to go to a
beach right now all right you want to
get out of the house you have the kids
who are making you a little crazy put
them in the car drive for hours to go to
a beach people would do that I thought
that so a couple right here in the
corner drove up from Queens to buy Thai
food in Styrofoam containers and sit in
the car and eat it I said why don't you
just buy food in Queens they said we
needed to take a ride I mean that's you
know look at that pent-up concern
in terms of coming up with our reopening
plan do you know when our plan will be
complete or we just still do we still
have too much of an issue here to even
get to that well the CDC guidance says
before any state should open you need
two weeks of flat or declining numbers
right so by the feds CDC guidance we're
not there yet right the two weeks is
flat or declining so even by a region
we'd have to do two weeks of flat or
declining the climbing is obviously
better than flat so if you're just
complying with the federal guidelines
you need that two weeks of case data so
our viewers are so interested in
antibody testing yesterday when you gave
the numbers I was curious
do you do you know how many tests that
you need to do for antibody testing
before you you'll feel comfortable you
could consume double the capacity of all
the labs in the state of New York to do
testing and you would not have done
enough you can never you'll always want
more testing you can never do enough
testing in the nursing homes in the
prisons and long-term care facilities
population at large you could never do
enough testing we're going to be in the
field for the next several weeks we
actually are in 15 locations downstate
today we're gonna be in other locations
on Saturday Sunday so this is gonna be
an ongoing thing as the governor said
yesterday as these results come in
yesterday's preliminary will keep
reporting those results out someone who
hasn't asked the question
statistical baseline I'm wondering if it
would be reasonable or feasible or
useful to mandate testing it would be
helpful but you have to have the
capacity for them to do that they are
now testing I don't know how many are
testing maybe the dr. Zorka does but
yeah you want we have testing in nursing
homes we're doing a lot of testing in
nursing homes but checking the
temperature of every staff member that
comes in we're not in a position to say
every we can provide enough tests to do
every staff member every day but do you
know any of them couldn't give you the
exact numbers but as the governor said
it's a comprehensive plan Apple
screening testing evaluating what else
they the concerns of infection and
spread so we're working on that and
we're looking at the possibility of how
we can as the governor mentioned test
staff as well as individuals with
because it's his test that's why he
believes this is not somebody else's
test
my confidence is in wodsworth lab test
as the governor said which has a
unbelievable sensitivity and specificity
we are ready for those who are getting
tested they want the results we provide
them with their results and an
information sheet about what those
results mean the antibody tests you're
talking about our commercial antibody
tests that are available this antibody
test was developed specifically by the
New York State Department of Health it's
our own test let's take one more got it
system the health emergency response
data system this is something that the
Douglas County Executive is seeking do
you know what that is they say it again
health emergency response data system we
received the data about all this
information at the County Health
Department's want to know if we're happy
to share that information with them
Thank You Dennis if you're watching
thank you very much northeast air
[Applause]
probable probable is what the times
added to actual deaths to be a little
misleading because probable is probable
but it's not actual but as soon as we
get the at home deaths we will add them
to the actual deaths but probable is not
actual so it's coming from local
government and what we don't the mission
whatever the coroner's reports are there
they are handled locally and given to
the state when we get them we release